old friends uh zingman freud and carl
young so how vast is this
uh
landscape of the unconscious mind the
power and the scope of the dictator is
uh is it only dark there
is it uh some light is there some love
the vast majority of what's happening in
your head you are unaware of so in a
literal sense the
unconscious the aspects of your mind
that you're not conscious of is the
overwhelming majority but but that's
just true in a literal engineering sense
your mind is doing lots of low-level
things and you just can't be consciously
aware of all that low-level stuff but
there's plenty of room there for lots of
things you're not aware of
but can we try to shine a light at the
things we're unaware of
specifically now again staying with the
philosophical psychology side for a
moment
you know can you shine the light in the
jungian shadow can you
what what's going on there what is this
machine like like what what level of
thoughts are happening there is it uh
something that could we can even
interpret if we somehow could visualize
it is it something that's human
interpretable or is it just a kind of
chaos of
like monitoring different systems in the
body making sure you're
happy making sure you're um fed all
those kind of basic forces that form
abstractions on top of each other and
they're not introspective at all we
humans are social creatures plausibly
being social is the main reason we have
these unusually large brains therefore
most of our brain is devoted to being
social
and so the things we're very obsessed
with and constantly paying attention to
are
how do i look to others
what would others think of me if they
knew these various things they might
learn about me so that's close to being
fundamental to what it means to be human
is caring what others think right to to
be
trying to present a story that would be
okay for what other things but we're
very constantly thinking what do other
people think so let me ask you this
question then about you robin hansen who
many places
sometimes for fun sometimes as a basic
statement of principle
likes to disagree with with what the
majority of people think
um
so how do you explain um
how are you self-deceiving yourself in
this task
and how are you being self how's your
like why is the dictator manipulating
you inside your head to be self-critical
like there's norms why do you want to
stand out
in this way why do you want to challenge
the norms in this way almost by
definition i can't tell you what i'm
deceiving myself about
but the more practical strategy that's
quite feasible is to ask about what are
typical things that most people decease
themselves about and then to own up to
those particular things sure what's
what's that what's a good one so for
example
i can very much acknowledge that i would
like to be well thought of
yes that i would be seeking uh attention
and glory and uh praise yes from my
intellectual work and that that would be
a major agenda driving my
intellectual attempts
um
so you know if there were topics that
other people would find less interesting
i might be less interested in those for
that reason for example i might want to
find topics whether people are
interested and i might want to
um go for the glory of finding a big
insight rather than a small one
and maybe one that was especially
surprising
that's also of course consistent with
some more ideal concept of what an
intellectual should be
but
most intellectuals are relatively
risk-averse they are
in some local intellectual tradition and
they are adding to that and they are
staying conforming to the sort of usual
assumptions and usual accepted beliefs
and practices of a particular area
so that they can be accepted in that
area and you know treat it as part of
the community
but you might think
for the purpose of the larger
intellectual project of understanding
the world better
people should be less eager to just add
a little bit to some tradition and they
should be looking for what's neglected
between the major traditions and major
questions they should be looking for
assumptions maybe we're making that are
wrong they should be looking at ways
things that are very surprising like
things that would be
uh you would have thought a priory
unlikely that once you are convinced of
it you find that to be very important
and uh
and a big update right so um
you could say that
one motivation i might have is less
motivated to be sort of comfortably
accepted into some particular
intellectual community and more willing
to just go for these
more fundamental
long shots that should be very important
if you could find them
which would if so if you can find them
would get you
appreciated respect
across a larger number of people across
the longer time span of history right so
like maybe the the small local community
will say you suck
right you must conform but the larger
community will see the brilliance of you
breaking out of the cage of the small
conformity into a larger cage it's
always a bigger there's always a bigger
page and then you'll be remembered by
more
you